good morning Hank it's Tuesday so a week
from today marks a huge moment of
progress for human health as the patent
on the drug badaquiline expires allowing
less expensive generic versions to be
produced that can cure far more people
living with multi-drug resistant
tuberculosis wait what's that
oh well that's unfortunate what will
actually happen next Tuesday is that the
company Johnson and Johnson will begin
enforcing a secondary patent thus
denying access to badaquiline to around
6 million people over the next four
years and that's where we come in
nerdfighteria because I really think
that if we can understand this problem
together and make a compelling case to
Johnson and Johnson that they are
pursuing a bad business strategy we can
save a lot of lives but first some
history tuberculosis is the world's
deadliest infectious disease it killed
about 30 000 people last week which is
especially horrifying given that it is
usually curable generally with a
cocktail of drugs given daily over four
months a drug resistant TB that isn't
cured by that cocktail is a growing
problem so between the 1940s and the
1960s we developed and synthesized eight
different classes of drugs that could
treat tuberculosis and then between the
1960s and the end of the 20th century
tree no new drugs were developed to
treat tuberculosis for the simple reason
that we stopped investing money in TB
treatments because it was no longer a
problem in rich countries now for the
record if we continue this strategy of
global Health caring about infectious
disease only when it affects rich
countries we will continue to see more
and more drug resistance until
eventually a strain of disease emerges
that we can't cure which will spread
globally and cause a pandemic which will
affect rich countries and that's one
reason to end TB now another reason is
that all human lives are equally
valuable and it's completely
unacceptable that this year 1.6 million
people will die of a curable disease
right so we had these last decades where
we didn't discover any new TB treatments
but then the incentives changed
government started to invest much more
in research and even in like funding
trials making it more interesting to
pharmaceutical companies and eventually
Johnson and Johnson developed a new drug
called bedaquiline now most of the money
that went into researching and
discovering badaka lean came from the
public it came from governments but
Johnson and Johnson did take some risks
did invest some money full credit and
that's why in 2003 they got to file a
patent for the drug compound bedaquiline
then in 2007 they filed a secondary
patent for bedaquiline with this added
Fumarate salt now one expert recently
explained this to me as filing a patent
for a pen cap that goes with your pen
like a pen cap makes your pen work
better and last longer but it's not the
pen and indeed Johnson and Johnson
always knew that they were going to have
to develop a pen cap for their pen they
waited until 2007 precisely so that they
could extend the length of their patent
so bedakylene becomes available to the
public and it has saved hundreds of
thousands of lives like a couple months
ago I was in Sierra Leone and spoke with
two young women who were dying of
tuberculosis who were on their death bed
when they received this new cocktail of
drugs containing badakaline they quickly
recovered today they are cured they are
home with their families and they are
attending school that's the power of
this drug but while the price of it has
dropped over the last decade it is still
way too expensive for many communities
like a study by msf indicated that if
generics were allowed to be produced
globally the price of badaquiline would
drop by 67 percent from a dollar fifty a
pill to 50 cents per pill and that
should be happening next Tuesday because
the original 2003 patent for bedakylene
expires on July 18 2023 but
unfortunately in many countries Johnson
and Johnson is using that secondary
patent on the pen cap to extend their
exclusivity for four more years during
those four years experts estimate that
up to 6 million people who would have
access to badakaline in a world of
generics won't be able to afford it and
most of those people will die so if it
sounds like I'm angry that's because I'm
angry but I think we can make change
here thanks to lawsuits filed by TB
survivors led by two extraordinary young
women courts have decided that the pen
cap is not adequate Innovation and so
they have not granted the patent which
means that there are right now generic
manufacturers ready to go making
badakuli Unfortunately they won't be
able to distribute those generic
medications to many countries with a
high TB burden including Sierra Leone
and that's why I'm hoping we come in
because we need to explain to Johnson
and Johnson that this is a bad decision
like Johnson Johnson is not some evil
monolith it's a company made out of
people and I genuinely believe that most
of those people want their work to make
the world better I mean J J's corporate
Credo begins we believe our first
responsibility is to the patients and I
want them to live up to that Credo so
there are links in the video info below
and an append comment to contact Johnson
and Johnson and let them know that you
find this attempt to Evergreen their
patent rep apprehensible and completely
out of line with their Credo there are
also links to jnj's social media tag
them share the news that badaquiline's
patent should be expiring saving so many
lives but instead is being immorally
evergreened by Johnson and Johnson tell
your friends about this Injustice tell
your family tell the internet because
the only reason Johnson and Johnson
Executives think they can get away with
this is that they think we aren't paying
attention in the part of the world where
they sell most of their products their
Band-Aids their Tylenol their Listerine
and if you work at Johnson and Johnson
or know someone who does let the company
and the executives know about your
opposition to the extension of this
patent tell your bosses tell your CEO as
I said before bedackling has done so
much good and a big part of that good is
because of the work that researchers and
other people working at jnj put into it
but the time has come for this drug
funded primarily by the public to be
returned to the public as a public good
and to the executives of Johnson and
Johnson from one CEO to another I just
want to make a direct plea this is a bad
business decision a company's reputation
is extremely valuable and denying
badakaline to six million people over
the next four years will be very bad for
your reputation there are a lot of
people who pay a little bit extra for
your Neosporin than generic Neosporin
because they trust it and this decision
is undermining that trust harming those
Brands is bad business and when you
attempt to Evergreen a patent even
though you know the decision will cost
hundreds of thousands of human lives
over the next four years you're
tarnishing your corporate reputation
I'll quote it back to you our first
responsibility is to the patients I hope
you will Embrace that promise and until
you do we will pressure you to live up
to your Credo so let's get to work
bringing about a world where people no
longer die AI every day for want of
badakulin links below Hank I will see
you on Friday